[Music]
yo what's up guys mkbhd here welcome
back to quarantined content just a
little entertainment for you while some
of us are staying inside i'm your host
marquez brownlee and uh
you remember the cyber truck right made
a lot of headlines mean angles
no curves at all pretty unconventional
looking to say the least but then after
that do you remember all the articles
that came out about the phone that was
based on the cyber truck that was going
to come out just a few weeks later
well
i have it here and this is this is
perfect quarantine content because
nobody's actually thinking about buying
this phone but
i figured i'd check it out anyway
because we just have that kind of time
now so this is called the caviar iphone
11 pro max
cyberphone
and i guess it's really appropriately
named because that's really all this is
it's an iphone 11 pro built into a
casing that looks
somewhat like a cyber truck i guess you
know there are definitely no curves to
this body at all it's uh very angular
it's a straight up rectangle uh stands
on its own very industrial looking so
sure i guess i see it and it also like
the cyber truck is huge so it turns the
regular-sized iphone into a really wide
heavy like brick-like object that would
honestly probably be better as a
self-defense projectile than anything
else the cyber truck used cold rolled
stainless steel as it's like outside
body panels giving it that distinctive
look the cyber truck phone
well can the cyber can i call wait hold
on elon can they call it the cyber truck
phone oh it's the cyber phone right okay
maybe that's safe so the cyber phone
also uses bare metal as you can tell and
it's it's titanium they say now they
sent me this review sample which they
say is aluminum but the final versions
will be titanium if they ship any but
just overall you get the picture you
already know what an iphone is and you
know what it looks like just imagine it
in a case
made of curveless metal with some clicky
button cutouts and grooves on the sides
in fact that's really what it is you
know the more you look at it the more it
just looks like an iphone in a
ridiculous case and it costs
7
000
so
yeah that's this is why i preface this
by saying it's it's ridiculous no one in
their right mind would pay thousands of
dollars for an iphone in a metal case
right but then again here's the thing
about pricing why would a thousand
dollar phone wrapped in three hundred
dollars of metal suddenly cost seven
thousand dollars
you may be having flashbacks to the
video i did not too long ago about why
apple's charging seven hundred dollars
for the wheels to the mac pro basically
the pricing has everything to do with
this logo on the back here caviar yes
they are also the ones that made that
hundred thousand dollar gold iphone i
reviewed last year you can imagine if
incipio or like otterbox or somebody
tried to sell a metal case for the
iphone like this how much could they get
away with selling a case like this for
199
maybe 249
at the most but caviar is doing their
thing going way over the top with the
fancy packaging and then the whole bunch
of separately packaged accessories in
there and the ton of paperwork including
a certificate of authenticity and a
bunch of advertising for their other
products you might see a sort of a theme
here so where you and i see a six month
old iphone wrapped in a metal case for
seven thousand dollars
caviar and its customers potentially
see another tech themed accessory
collectible
that happens to be riding the press wave
of the actual cyber truck
bingo it's kind of dumb actually like
the more you actually hold this and just
look at it and and try to use it the
more you realize this case actually
makes the iphone experience
worse
and i know a lot of people buy nice cars
and put them in a garage and maybe those
same people buy this phone and never use
it but if you try to use this because
that's my job uh there's a couple things
you might notice that are pretty bad
there's a sharp metal lip at the bottom
of the phone where you're supposed to
swipe up for all your gestures every
time you unlock so that's pretty
unfortunate the lightning port at the
bottom is now recessed pretty far in
thanks to the thickness of the case
which means every time i try to use any
higher quality lightning cable other
than the cheap one that comes with the
iphone it doesn't work because it
doesn't actually reach the lightning
port it's too far recessed also as you
may have imagined a thick metal case
like this nukes wireless charging so you
can say goodbye to that feature too
and i haven't tested the antenna
performance but i can't imagine a case
like this improves signal strength at
all
and there's also this huge hole on the
side because that's where the sim card
ejector tray is now they included this
fancy tool which is metal with both a
pin and a hook on it and that's because
in order to fish the sim card tray out
of this case you need both to eject it
and then use that hook to fish it out
basically which is
i mean i guess it's cool that they
thought of that but geez now that is an
ugly hole in the side of your case so
after all this i thought you know what
maybe it's a durability angle you know
this thing's a tank
the cyber truck played the durability
angle pretty well after all well
pretty well
[Music]
but i figured hey you know what maybe
this metal enclosure holds up to drops
better
but little did i know it would have its
own cyber truck window moment i dropped
the phone one time
on video that's the only time i've
dropped it and just like the cyber truck
the glass cracked so
it's not entirely a bulletproof strategy
also you may remember the promo videos
with this dramatic folding piece over
the front of the screen for protection
and ergonomics but this one doesn't
actually have that see this is the
cybertruck phone or cyberphone lite
and that one doesn't have any moving
pieces but on their site you can step up
to the full on cyberphone for 7
680
which gets you that fancy ergonomic
plate thing or you can step all the way
up to the 20 000
cyberphone billionaire edition
where the the body is made of silver
with gold accents
i'm pretty isn't silver a pretty soft
metal actually
well that probably won't hold up to
drops well but there you have it the
cyber truck phone from all those videos
and all those headlines does exist in
real life and it's ridiculous and nobody
should actually buy one but you know
what as a reward for making it to the
end of this video about a ridiculous
thing you should never buy
uh you get a chance to win one so i'll
be giving away this my uh cracked
aluminum review sample of the cyberphone
i'll be giving it away on twitter in the
next few days so definitely follow over
there if you want to get entered and
have a shot at it
and also let me know what you think
about this thing in the comments section
below
also you can always grab some merch if
you want to support the channel link
below for that as well
that's been pretty much it
thanks for watching
catch you guys very soon in the next one
peace